it's not up there wasn't much left by
the way but there was enough I get it
okay final Mic Check final Mic Check for
anybody who needs it this is a Mic Check
final Mic Check 1 2 3 4 we should be
getting started here any minute
final last words right anybody need a
white balance before we get started I've
got the official state of California
white sheet
all right we should be getting started
here any minute
yeah
was just told that the Wi-Fi guest
network is unavailable
do you have a wife
actually I really can't are you uh
translating for us mark what are you
guys so we can get everybody you guys
all getting alright well welcome
everybody and thank you for the
opportunity to update folks I imagine
many of you here situationally to
understand what was announced yesterday
in more detail and specificity as it
relates to the first apparently first a
community sourced transfer the virus I
want to first though contextualize this
moment and contextualize California's
role as it relates to the issue that is
in front of us I've been very proud to
be a resident of this great state for
over 50 years the privilege of growing
up in in around San Francisco through
the HIV and AIDS epidemic my saw
firsthand the incredible capacity and
resolve and compassion empathy Drive the
innovative spirit that defined our March
to meet those moments in the past how
richly resourced we were not just
financially but in spirit and in resolve
I had the opportunity over the course of
decades and public service as a County
Supervisor and as mayor of a County San
Francisco to work very closely and
collaboratively with the state of
California federal agencies to address
issues large and small issues around
MERS and SARS issues around h5n1 not
just h1n1 issues around Ebola and our
response to those situational challenges
in crises I saw firsthand the incredible
expertise and commitment and resolve of
people at all level of government and as
a consequence many of those things
are in our rearview mirror as it relates
to the acuity of our consciousness and
focus accordingly we'll meet this moment
we will Express and advance similar
resolve on the issue of this novel
coronavirus and we will accordingly
attach ourselves to a little bit
understanding of our history and our
capacity to meet pandemics head-on both
in pre-planning both addressing pandemic
in real time and more importantly in
many respects post pandemic over the
course of decades now the state of
California formally has adopted some
renewed strategies and those strategies
are advanced on an annual basis through
formal efforts at the local level
regional state and federal level to work
to build capacity and build partnerships
the state of California invested
millions of dollars a year to require
communities large and small in this
state to advance protocols to do very
comprehensive annual event plans and to
continue to develop relationships not
just develop policies and planning
documents relationships and trust at the
end of the day matter more than anything
else we had a number of those by the way
conducted at scale last November it was
just a month or so later last December
that we first were afforded the
opportunity to learn more about what was
happening overseas in Asia I very proud
of being a former mayor of San Francisco
with the first and largest Chinatown in
the United States when the largest
Chinese populations Asian populations
more broadly defined per capita in a
part of our country accordingly being
governor of the most diverse state in
the world's most diverse democracy also
affords us a capacity of understanding
and again strong formal relationships
that have been developed over the course
of decades those relationships allowed
us to advance in real time
understanding and scoping of the
challenge that inevitably
would be presented we worked more
formally with the Trump administration
and continued to work formally and very
collaboratively with the Trump
administration at all levels to
coordinate and collaborate that
coordination and collaboration you may
recall initiated in a number of
repatriation flights that came to the
United States and rather than turning
our backs on those repatriation flights
we support it with partnerships at CDC
and other federal agencies those
repatriation efforts as American
citizens first as Californians advancing
our values second and we coordinated
those first flights the first flight in
particular in January late January down
into Riverside at Marsh we've had a
number of other flights including the
most recent at Travis Air Force Base in
Solano County over 800 people have come
in on those flights but that's a small
part of the overall picture thousands
and thousands of other people have come
in on more traditional flights through
the state of California some eighty four
hundred plus are currently being
monitored with 49 local jurisdictions
doing those protocols and monitoring as
it relates to more traditional
commercial flights that came in from
points of concern and potential points
of contact particularly in Asia as you
may know as of today and I say as of
today at this hour
we have 33 confirmed positive tests for
the virus five individuals have
subsequently moved out of state so
they're 28 people that we know in the
state of California that are positive
the case yesterday understandably
generated a lot of attention but didn't
surprise any of the folks standing to my
left or right we knew this was
inevitable as it relates to the nature
the epidemiology the nature of these
viruses that that incident would occur
accordingly
when hearing about it we initiated a
series of protocols that we were
prepared to advance those protocols
include deep tracking and tracing of
individuals that would be in contact
with this individual working again in
collaboration of partnership with our
federal partners and working with the
extraordinary extraordinarily talented
and committed frontline workers both in
the healthcare sector and but more
broadly defined at the local and county
level we are currently in deep
partnership with CDC on one overriding
protocol that drives our principle focus
right now and that's testing and the
importance to increase our testing
protocols and a point of contact
diagnostic testing as our top priority
not just in the state of California but
I imagine all across the United States
we had conversations
just don't say moments ago but within
last few hours with CDC assuring us that
the testing protocols will be advanced
with urgency we have just a few hundred
testing kits in the state of California
and that's surveillance testing as well
as diagnostic testing that's simply
inadequate to do justice to the kind of
testing that is required to address this
issue head-on and I'm very pleased the
CDC is moving expeditiously on that and
have made firm commitments to the state
of California that will significantly
and exponentially expand our capacity to
advance those testing protocols nothing
more important than point of contact
diagnostic testing that could be readily
made available so that we can have full
full spectrum testing of this disease
and so that is or rather this virus and
so that's our top priority as it relates
to the moment and again we are pleased
with the response that we have just
received from our representatives of the
federal government we have today though
represent
a number of state agencies that will
talk more learnedly
and more specifically about the
protocols and procedures that are
underway as it relates to modeling this
virus in the state looking at vaccine
protocols when not if when the vaccine
avails itself looking at the strategies
of cooperation at a multi jurisdictional
level be it not just with state and
local and federal officials but also
nonprofits NGOs and private sector
participants that's why we have
assembled here today the head of our
Health and Human Service Agency who will
speak just after me he'll hand it off to
dr. angel who represents public health
system and someone many of you in
California quite familiar with the head
of our office emergency services not to
elevate anxiety in relationship to the
officer emergency services but our
leader as it relates to wildfires and
relating to natural disasters but also
our leader in logistics as it relates to
the modeling and gaming out of our next
phase strategies if they aren't
necessary I long winded Li have just
said the following we're meeting this
moment we have been in constant contact
with federal agencies we have history
and expertise in this space we are not
overreacting but nor are we under
reacting to the understandable anxiety
many people have as it relates to this
novel virus at the same time no better
resource state in America to address
this issue head-on and no better team
assembled that have taken account and
responsibility from day one to meet this
moment so it's in that spirit that I now
will ask dr. Ghali
to come up and express his points of
view and he will pass his podium on to
the two other representatives of
agencies and we're here of course to
answer any question
subs claim they have dr. Ghali thank you
Thank You governor my name is dr. mark
gallium secretary for California's
Health and Human Services Agency today I
want to walk through what we alongside
our colleagues at the governor's office
Cal OES our local partners our private
partners in the hospital system the
clinic system our many physicians and
nurses across the state have been
working towards as well as our great
partnership with the CDC and other
federal agencies we are here and have
been doing our work around the clock for
many weeks and months now to protect
California's health and safety since we
first learned about the novel
coronavirus I will then turn this over
to dr. Sonya Angel to my right who is
our California public health officer who
is also the director of the California
Department of Public Health and she will
go into more detail about specifics on
the particular case that I know many of
you are interested in learning more
about I do want to spend a moment to
setting a bit of a ground rule around
what we'll do here today as a physician
along with dr. angel we take very
seriously patient privacy we may not be
able to be in a position to answer
questions about the most recent case
when it comes to the condition of the
patient the their age and where they are
we are also not going to be discussing
in great detail issues around the
federal repatriation efforts as many of
you are aware we are in active
conversations and in litigation around
that with our federal partners and the
local entities I want to start by saying
it's natural to feel concerned about the
novel coronavirus but I want
Californians to know that we have
rigorously planned for this public
health event just like this as the
governor mentioned when I was with him
in San Francisco we prepared for the
h1n1 situation we've gone through this
with Ebola and being prepared and many
other events like it in the past and our
goal is to take
every precaution to protect California's
health and safety this is a rapidly
evolving situation we are leveraging all
the necessary state resources to address
it we are in constant communication with
our federal partners and yes it was just
moments ago that we were on with the
CDC's director learning about our
ability to expand testing here in the
state to receive more testing kits and
to be an active conversation on
redefining what triggers a situation a
clinical situation to be tested
California continues to be an active
federal an active partner with the
federal government helping lots of
impacted Americans get home as the
governor said we welcomed home the first
first of many flights to the state we
have been participating with all of our
public health resources our clinical
resources to support those federal
efforts we are the first in the nation
to begin to roll out testing and we are
going to be expanding that in the hours
to come we have been actively and
extensively planning with our local
health partners that includes our
delivery system the hospitals and
doctors and nurses that we all trust
have been deeply engaged I'm grateful
for those wonderful partnerships and
relationships we have with those
agencies and organizations across the
state because those relationships matter
at a moment like this it makes it more
seamless and gives us a better chance to
be prepared as we have experienced in
the last many weeks as in any public
health event our medical and health
coordination center has been activated
and is coordinating its response across
the state and preparing for more and
possible community transmission
California continues to prepare and
respond in coordination with even our
local hospitals in Solano County and in
many other counties that have stepped to
the plate and really taken on a clinical
load that weeks ago wasn't anticipated
we are providing information guidance in
documents and in technical assistance in
regular
phone calls and webinars with all of our
state partners who need to continue to
work with us to make sure that we have
the best interest of all Californians in
mind this includes guidance to
facilities such as schools universities
colleges childcare centers all across
California because the questions are
many and we want to make sure we give a
consistent and clear voice we continue
to coordinate with the federal
authorities and local health departments
and implementing screening monitoring
and in some cases quarantine we've had
over 8,000 passengers returning to the
u.s. from China and other parts of Asia
over the past many weeks and we have
supported and worked with our local
health departments to make sure those
individuals are safe and that we are
giving good and appropriate guidance
based on the most up-to-date information
we are continuing to work with our
federal partners on giving our feedback
on all of their guidance and criteria so
that we make sure that it is current and
meets the needs of an evolving situation
we look forward to continuing those
strong relationships and we are working
hard to ensure that our local health
capacity is preserved for those
individuals with significant symptoms if
that is developed so we are working hard
to make sure that our local health
partners are communicating accurately
when people who are experiencing
symptoms whether they've had exposure or
not should be emerging and coming
forward to health facilities we live in
an age where telehealth telemedicine
phone advice many other types of modes
of getting information and sharing your
clinical condition exist and we are
urging many folks to use that before
they come to emergency rooms or urgent
care centers or their physicians
practices in order that we ensure that
the hospitals and our capacity during a
important time in
season and when other emerging other
patients with clinical needs would
naturally use the emergency rooms so
we're trying to work hard with those
partners to make sure that we use our
scarce but critical access within our
acute care hospitals in the most
responsible and appropriate matter I
will now turn to dr. sunny angel who
will go in to more detail about sort of
state of affairs of coronavirus across
the globe across the nation in our state
and some of the specifics on the
important development from yesterday dr.
angel hi good morning I'm dr. Sonya
angel I'm director of the California
Department of Public Health and State
Public Health Officer and I'm welcoming
you all today here to our medical health
Coordination Center this is where we
coordinate with all of our agencies a
very important response that we've put
in place for novel coronavirus otherwise
known as kovat 19 not a de coronal virus
koban 19 is new but it is part of a
family of corona viruses that have been
around for a long time that we are very
familiar with
in fact corona viruses are responsible
for the common cold so it's something
that all of you may also be quite
familiar with the cause of the current
outbreak that originated in China is a
new member of this family the most
common symptoms of kovat 19 include
fever cough and shortness of breath our
experience to date though is that most
people more than 85% will have mild or
no symptoms
some may move to a more complicated
course including pneumonia but that is
not the most common manifestation of
novel coronavirus we're learning more
about its transmission and as I said the
most common symptoms are respiratory
therefore its primary mode of
transmission is from coughing or
sneezing particularly when we don't
cover our mouths after we sneeze or
cough or don't wash our hands there have
been a limited number of confirmed cases
of Kovan 19 in California
today as mentioned 33 positive cases in
California 24 were from the repatriation
flights the other nine confirmed cases
include seven that are travel related
one due to person-to-person contact but
that was from a very close contact a
spouse living in the home and now is
mentioned yesterday this new case from
an unknown source this particular case
could be the first possible instance of
community transmission of kovat 19 in
the United States and it's here in
California it's in an individual in
Solano County who is receiving care in
Sacramento County with no travel history
and no known exposure to somebody with
confirmed kovat 19 we currently have
people in the field working in the
community at the local from this from
the local the state and also from the
CDC they're investigating the cases and
they're taking action they're contacting
any individuals who might have been
exposed and they're isolating them this
is a fluid situation at this time and I
want to emphasize that the risk to the
general public remains low in the event
that that risk changes we will
communicate with you we will make
everyone aware but it's important to
note that the risk the risk to the
general public in California remains low
from novel coronavirus the Department of
Public Health's emergency operate
operation center has been actively
coordinating response efforts preparing
for possible community transmission as
always in emergencies we plan for both
the worst situation but also the best
situation so we're ready for anything
we've been working with our state and
local partners for situations like this
for over a decade we've updated our
plans based upon our lessons that we
learned from h1n1 and from Avala by
Ebola virus but we do realize that this
case that we're discussing today marks a
turning point and as such we're
expanding our surveillance activities
we're increasing our laboratory capacity
is mentioned with more testing we're
planning increased increased demands on
our
chuckle system and we're using the
latest science to model and forecast the
needs of our communities so that we are
sure we can continue to respond as we
have today as we learn more about kovat
19 and how it evolves we will be sure
that we adapt whatever we're doing to
make sure that our responses are
appropriate and as we continue to work
in coordination with federal and local
partners there are some simple steps
that I want to remind all of you we're
all emphasized this that you can do
today to make sure that you stay safe
and to protect yourself and those
include washing your hands with soap and
water avoiding touching your eyes no
their nose their mouth with unwashed
hands staying at home from work or
school if you become sick with
respiratory system symptoms like a fever
or cough and avoiding close contact with
people who are sick it's natural to be
concerned at times like this which is
why California officials have been
closely closely monitoring and working
with partners around the situation now
I'd like to turn this over to California
Office of Emergency Services director
mark Gillard do Qi thanks dr. angel good
morning mark Narducci director of the
governor's office of emergency services
first let me just say as you've heard
today this is a new and rapidly evolving
situation and a challenge to us but we
are doing everything at the state level
in support of our local partners to
address it this is not our first time as
it's been mentioned by previous speakers
that we have addressed similar kinds of
challenges currently my office the
office of emergency services is
primarily supporting the great team at
the Health and Human Services Agency and
California Department of Public Health
with all or any resources coordination
activities and we're actually leveraging
all the very powerful and broad
authorities of OAS and of our great
emergency response system to be able to
meet whatever needs that HHS has to
ensure that they have all the items they
need particularly like areas in
commodities or
assets that that may be necessary we're
also doing a lot of cross coordination
and communications with jurisdictions
around the state to ensure that our
local operational areas meet all the
needs to in the event that they're
having trouble facing whatever
challenges they face again much like we
do in the normal course of emergencies
that we routinely face here in
California and like all emergencies it's
critical to understand that there are
risks and as Ben mentioned we want to
encourage everyone to have a family plan
and review that with your family and we
really listen to state and local health
authorities as they continue to provide
critical information out to the public
this is going to be a little bit of a
marathon and so we're going to be
continuing to support and as it evolves
or changes what we prepare to do that in
an effort of bringing all different
state agencies and departments together
where we're doing advance planning for
any potential scenario that may take
place in the coming weeks or months so
again I just want to close by
emphasizing that while we face this new
challenge we need to know that the state
is taking every action and and we want
to encourage you to just continue to
listen to your state and local health
officials thank you so happy to take any
questions and again with the one
criteria of respect and responsibility
that we have to patient privacy I
imagine many of you want to know who she
is how many people she is in contact
with where she works and those clearly
are understandable questions and I hope
you an anticipation of our responses
understand our patient responsibility to
protect and preserve confidentiality but
know that we are intimately involved in
answering those questions of the kind of
specificity there's quite at the moment
you tell us when this person came to the
Northern California Hospital how many
days went by before they came to yeah I
leave that to dr. Ghali we can't give
all of the details that reveal that we
know that there were a number of days
that she was in her community and that
she then did begin accessing care and
through the course of her care as her
condition condition evolved
she was then tested so there were days
in between when she emerged with
symptoms and when the test actually
occurred but we we have been working
closely with those healthcare delivery
systems that took care of her as well as
the CDC and others to make sure we're
doing all the appropriate things to
understand what community exposure
existed and what we can do to make sure
those who were exposed received the
right care and concern that we would
want any of our family members to
receive that we're in that situation no
it underscores the importance of the
testing protocols being advanced and as
we said the information we received from
the CDC this morning advanced those
protocols and so we are satisfied and
we're now moving in the right direction
accordingly we have a tracing protocol
that's best-in-class meaning every
single point of contact every point of
contact of those that were in contact
all of those will be resourced and
reviewed accordingly CDC has committed
to sending ten of their personnel into
the state of California to help assist
in those efforts to broaden our capacity
to track each one of those individuals
in to make sure that they're contacted
and to make sure that they're
interviewed
leave that time again my medical team we
have no evidence that there is any
connection with those patients in this
individual at this time I can't give you
those specific numbers but I can tell
you that investigation started yesterday
they continue across the full spectrum
from the individuals home all the way
through the hospital system and all of
them are being reviewed carefully by by
those people in the field at this time I
can't give you the number at this time
no state was no state had the ability to
access them I don't want to get into the
but let's just establish this new
protocols are now being advanced they
can't happen soon enough testing
protocols have been a point of
frustration for many of us across the
spectrum and I mean means cross not only
spectrum and then the Health System but
across states we have as I said just 200
kits and that's for not just the
traditional diagnostic but also
surveillance it's simply inadequate but
no longer will that be the case later
this afternoon tomorrow in the next few
days we have been assured of our
capacity to significantly exponentially
increase the capacity to test and this
is something that again is critical at
this moment we've been I don't look I'm
not gonna politicize this moment and I'm
not going to point fingers and I'm gonna
speak honestly and forthrightly that we
have had a very strong working
relationship with the administration
from the secretary level to the director
level we have been in consistent contact
not only as a team but individually I
have as well from day one and to the
extent that they are processing their
own protocols and procedures we are
grateful that in that iterative
engagement they are moving forward as we
and in advancing our efforts to test to
the extent necessary you know
emergencies often are to emphasize
energy of focus often just for federal
purposes of receiving additional
resources and support right now I don't
feel either are necessary the attention
is understandably focused the money is
not the issue at the moment but to the
extent conditions changed we'll consider
that I'm not concerned about them at all
today
and I finished my job here today
[Music]